you booked guests and you don't know who
they are and intentionally and then you
try and figure out who these celebrities
are because you don't know much about
celebrity culture pop culture and you
spend the whole interview just trying to
figure out who they are
mm-hmm then and they play along they
know they're being booked and that you
don't know who they are yeah they have
to they have to be okay with it yeah and
but yeah I'm given a sheet of different
famous faces and and then I go through
and say yes no yes no and a lot of times
they'll stop on a picture the producers
will be like wait you don't know who
this is like no they're like let me pull
up some other Google images they're like
okay I'm like I have no I've never seen
this person in my life and they can't
believe it
right yeah it's kind of shocking first
of all you don't know who a lot of
people are it's just a problem for you
in the real world I mean just outside
the show you're living out here in
Hollywood yeah I could happen is it get
awkward I did have a what my most recent
very awkward moments was I was with the
creator of Star Trek in our hotel we
were we had come back from the wrap
party and we were at the hotel
and we were chatting before we went up
to our rooms and this woman came around
the corner this is so embarrassing
she came around the corner and she said
hey TIG and I said oh um I said wait you
were were you just at the Star Trek rap
party and she said no I'm Anne Hathaway
that's okay it's a very well-known a
list celebrity and Hathaway she said she
followed it up with I met you at the
Beck concert and I was like oh right and
then I went home and I told Stephanie my
wife and she was like oh my gosh she she
said I can't believe Anne Hathaway is
explaining who she is based on meeting
you had a Beck concert she said her
response should have been I'm Anne
Hathaway from Anne Hathaway now is this
been an issue like when you go and see a
movie you know do you know who people
are if you and your wife go and see a
movie you like know who the people on
the screen are we don't see a lot of
movies well I'll watch movies with her
at home and it truly I think it's like
reading when I watch something I fall
asleep and so it takes me we'll watch a
movie and it'll take three nights to
watch a movie and one of our first dates
we went I was actually just interviewed
by CNN about this show and I was telling
the interviewer on scene about how and
Stephanie and I first went out we went
to see a movie and I leaned over to her
and I said I said who is that guy and
she's and this is what I told the
interviewer on CNN that I said who is
that guy and Stephanie said you don't
know that is that's Al Pacino and and I
was III I I just I didn't and then when
Stephanie read the CNN article she was
like it wasn't Al Pacino it was Robert
De Niro you even got that wrong
but I it's truly just I follow music I
followed documentaries I follow the news
and you know some politics it's nothing
against anyway look it's pretty shocking
here's a clip of under Iraq and here
you're talking to someone I would think
you would know because she has been on a
very popular TV show for a long time
Julie Bowen and you're you have no idea
which is let's take a look okay so this
is your bow the bow is part of the name
bow it's a it's one of the syllables
that's it
what do you usually shoot with arrow
right but then what's the freeze bow and
Bowen that's your name
bow what's special about the bow look at
it look at it take what's on it what
makes this jewel jewel so and jewels
name is almost
mr. Heric now putting up with that